So in summary, for
this lesson, I've covered basic concepts of cross-correlation, convolution.
I've discussed the differences between cross-correlation and
convolution, as applied to image filtering, and of course,
I've also discussed the properties of convolution, and how we actually now can
generalize the whole process of how doing, how we can do filtering with images.
This has just been a foundational types of things.
And now we're actually with next lecture, we're going to start finding more
information from images, specifically things like edges and images, which
then will actually create the foundations for doing something we want to do.
That is feature matching.
All right? So we will be actually, taking what we've learned about filtering,
and now start getting content information out of images,
rather than just doing blurring and filtering that we've been doing.
And I noted I'd been using MatLab for
some, some of this stuff, but you should feel free to use whatever you want.
And I just always like to thank other people that I've borrowed some
concepts from.